[Music]
he must go he must go because he does
not believe in democracy nor the
supremacy of the judiciary he must go
because one of his advisors asserted his
powers quote will not be questioned he
must go because he believes Republican
Congressmen are only obligated to
represent Republican constituents he
must go because he is here only after
the interference of an enemy nation in
our election he must go because he
believes in conspiracy theories and in
his own intuition instead of the facts
and reality he must go because he
publicly spews those conspiracy theories
that would get anyone else marginalized
in our society yet television covers him
live and without fact correction and
when asked why a CNN reporter answers
blankly he's the president of the United
States he must go because not only do
his actions simplify the task of known
terrorist organizations but in many
cases his actions also qualify as a form
of emotional terrorism he must go
because he burns with seeming hatred
towards people of color he must go
because his purge of undocumented
Americans has already moved from the
outskirts of logic to the depths of
sadism and punishment he must go because
the crudeness of his words about women
have already been exceeded by the
coldness of his promised actions in
office against women he must go because
he is found in Environmental Secretary
who wants to pillage the environment and
a health secretary who wants to gut the
ACA Medicare and Medicaid and an
education secretary who seems dedicated
to make sure most of our children are
stupid he must go because he has chosen
to make his job not about serving the
people of this nation but about hearing
applause and about being real
did he must go because in one breath his
administration can promise not to use
Air Force One as a political prop and in
the next he can give a campaign speech
in an airport hangar near Air Force One
he must go because from the first minute
of his presidency it has been obsessed
on leveraging this sacred democracy for
his own personal financial profit he
must go because he has summoned from
ordinary Americans as certainly as if he
were invoking Devils the worst of what
is inside them he must go because the
last night in Sweden incident showed he
can't or he won't tell the difference
between terrorism and ordinary crimes
committed by legal immigrants he must go
because he has caused alarm and dismay
amongst our allies abroad and given
considerable comfort to our enemies you
must go because whether insane were
diseased or drugged or syphilitic or
intellectually challenged or simply evil
he seems not to be in control of his own
mind he must go because he called the
media the enemy of the people like
Stalin or Hitler would have and he must
go because his next enemy of the people
could be you he must go resist peace